hey guys merry valeri on the road
stories podcast here what's happening I
hope you guys have a great week hope you
guys had a great week uh two real quick
announcements one quicker than the other
the first one is I had so much fun doing
this episode of road stories and I
didn't even do an introduction we just
turned on the mics and got rolling and I
forgot to introduce our comedian so on
today's episode you will hear one Ian
gutowski sits in on the co-host see it's
always great to heavy and in when I have
a special guest he helps me move the
show forward he's a great guy check out
his stuff online if you can and my
special guest today is Adam Ferrara adam
has been killing it on the scene for a
long time the guy is one of my favorite
comedians out of Long Island I'm so
stoked to have him on the show they're
trying to get him on for a long time of
course you know Adam from uh Nurse
Jackie and he was on rescue me for the
longest time and right now he's just
killing it on top gear so a really
really funny guy really funny guy check
out his stuff and of course listen to
him today and the second announcement is
of course the Los Angeles podcast
festival coming up in just mere weeks my
friend mere weeks um as I suspected or
um maybe that's not the right word my
guess was supposed to be greg behrendt
and sadly we all know what's going on in
Greg's life right now he lost his
awesome sister Kristen Behrendt we rock
the comedy scene it really did everybody
love Kristen especially me so do to
those circumstances Greg is not going to
be able to be on the podcast at the
podcast festival he sends his apologies
and we were going to schedule him to get
it on a regular episode within the next
couple of months so I'll Greg's always
welcome on the show ah totally
understand Greg you'd obviously you do
what you got to do um and uh we're with
you now having said that who could i get
to replace one greg behrendt who could
fill the shoes
of the King sweater himself I can only
think of one person will anderson will
anderson will be the guest on road
stories at the LA podcast festival I'm
superstone I love having will on I've
had will on before he's hilarious uh
he's so funny obviously check out his
podcast and his stuff online and I might
see if I can get a couple other
Australian comics to come in and sit in
we'll talk about the road in australia
and the road and american the
differences there and all the fun that
goes along with that now remember you
can livestream the festival all weekend
just go to LA pod fest dot-com go to
livestream put in to put in the code
Road get five dollars off get five
dollars off and you can watch my show
you can watch the rest of the festival
and you can watch it up to 30 days after
so let's say you're staying up and
you're watching the MER on the road
stories you're like ass time to go to
bed you can sleep 29 days and still get
up and watch the festival so go to LA
pod fest com watch the festival it's
hilarious when you watch it live I get
people tweeting at me so don't forget to
do that tweet at me shoot me messages if
you have questions we'll talk more about
that but seriously live streaming it's
so much fun the first time I did it my
phone was blowing up from people
literally all over the world watching
asking questions making jokes
questioning my sexuality which is always
hilarious uh all right so that's it good
at leap ifs calm put in the promo code
road livestream the festival and I'm
looking forward to meeting you guys who
are coming out and I'm looking forward
to seeing the guys who've come out
before and are back again what's that
confusing probably until then here's a
question
life on the road it's a taco dangly
course representing guns and these
lights get the flights running with the
runs room black this bounced checks
great a bachelorette bumps in the front
making out for your side and mid lights
doing whoa more amazing murchman drive
the rental car has another megachurch
ting zhu skis vagina 50 cell phone is
gone one big law and order marathon
I opened for a hypnotist that guy
couldn't put anybody under I'm not
kidding you got hypnotized people in
Brooklyn it's a two-man job one guy
waves to watch the other guy hit
somewhere that happen so he's honest I
did a half hour warm up and and then it
brought the hypnotist on and I was a kid
I was just I was just starting and he
couldn't put anybody on those people
sitting up big on Jesus I hope I don't
drop off and act the fool in front of
people heckling the guy trying to put
him under and Rocky's jumping up and
down and go kick it back up their kid do
something so they pull him off stage I
gotta go up into another half hour so
are you serious and I became his I was
his favorite after that girl a safe exam
and and so friday i'm on friday nights
the late show only the older guys would
come in yeah girlfriends you know and I
they would sit there they would be would
do your act and some the lady got up
went to the bathroom I did a joke I did
joke about my girlfriend yelling at me
and turning into a Pterodactylus on
today you know whatever was and he's
like hey and lady comes back from the
bathroom and she sitting there and all
of a sudden the guy says in the middle
of Legos dude a bird joke again I went
what do that better joke again she
missed it I go sorry I can't go like do
to / joke again here's one of my
favorite I did the joke again and the
guy came over he shook my hand at the
end he's going you're very funny made me
laugh thank you very much he shook my
hand and there was a perfectly fold one
hundred dollar bills like origami I mean
I don't know how he did it but it had
the hundred on an angle it's like he
does this every day just shook my hand
the Frank Sinatra if it was great and
the rule of thumb was if the guys liked
you if the boys liked you on Friday
night they would come back saturday
night with the wives so they bring the
girlfriends there on Friday lake and
Saturday come and you don't say anything
like nice to see you again don't say
[ __ ] right you just do your show and you
would be still laugh as hard as they did
the first day just you know they loved
it or they didn't got to keep it up to
yeah yeah that was that toppers that was
called toppers comedy was there it was
on cropsey Avenue right by the announcer
was welcomed atop his comedy cabaret
conveniently located right across from
Caesars babe bizarre
I remember said it was exit five off the
belt parkway it's not there anymore no
now underneath the circles gym or
something early 90s late 80s ah no this
was early 90 what did you get started
July thirteenth 1988 wow I can't when I
person like open mic East Side comedy
club Huntington Long Island it's now a
pomodoro restaurant you started super
young yeah I was i I got out of jail he
just got out of college and I told my
parents well we've done one of your
things right I want to mine but I didn't
um I college was fun for a while like I
was playing your guitar back i was in a
band in college of barb and we're GOG go
along i went to marist college in
Poughkeepsie oh yeah my wife went to
Vassar oh okay she's mastered you we
still play bastard oh yeah sure I sleep
with rich girls let's cruise over here
Rutgers they don't know is that i'm
trying to be part of it i'm sorry i
wouldn't go to Riker I didn't go wait
was one of me I wanted to be part of
everything and I just know I just I'm
high school graduate let's go back to a
Vassar rich women what happened to my
wife's money she was a rich girl man all
the rich girls went to Vassar all the
lesbians went to Vassar knows that too
all right we have a lot to go through a
therapy my wife and I oh yeah not rich
or let's get rich or lesbian so there's
an open mic in Poughkeepsie there is it
was another like no no I would all right
here's what happened I went to college
and I was in a band and you know you
have those friends when you first year
college you drink too much and you're
away from home and and it was for me
it's like you make these friends I'm
gonna have these friends forever and
then you sober up your second here you
realize where did this weight come from
he's a drunk he owes me money what the
[ __ ] so I would go home I would go home
every weekend and work I was working in
a fence company was digging holes and
putting you know put up fences and cuz I
always worked I always had a job and I
was like yeah I don't need to get drunk
every friggin weekend and I have no
money so I would it was a two and a half
hour drive from Poughkeepsie to Long
Island where I was from so I would drive
home and do two days of work and then
drive up on on Monday morning to make my
afternoon class monday afternoon that I
never went to I always left to go to but
I would get to go I'm tired I just
[ __ ] drove to a yeah I go to sleep
mr. glad um so that's what I did every
weekend I went home
um and I would always see the comedy
club mm-hmm and I said yeah I got it
yeah i saw prior when i was a kid well i
went to not live I saw him I went to uh
we knows parties you go to with your mom
and dad where you get the warning in the
car where your mother turns around like
now your father does business with these
people don't behave like an animal so we
going in there watching Richard Pryor to
Santa Monica concert when Patti LaBelle
open forum so the adults go in the next
room to get the coffee I rewind the tape
I put it on and it just blew my head off
it's just I didn't think I wanted to be
a common but I was just profoundly moved
I remember say there's no one in the
room and I'm just remember saying look
what this man can do yeah they didn't
even introduce him he walked out and
grabbed the mic I just started riffing
he's like anyway that's why I like this
parts hello yes hello I like when
everyone comes back and and the white
people find out the black people have
done taking this seat is started going
and I the way I was hypnotized when he
did the black guy and a white guy
walking through the woods my heart
attack bit and i was like i like i said
i didn't really say i wanted to be that
but i'm sure that just move me how old
were you as a kid was 12 maybe she
wasn't crazy thing for me none of those
guys really affected me like corner why
cuz you're dead inside oh well that was
a crazy thing it's like those guys
Carlin Hicks and prior I didn't get
until I was 30 that was weird for me
we're like so when he hears some b12
that connected to the vulnerability of
priors what was the pesos that God I
didn't understand a lot of it like I
don't understand you just need something
special but it was just I was I was that
just felt connected the way he was
holding that audience and he was just
and just watching mandeville yeah and
it's like i like i said i don't think i
could consciously process what was going
on but i remember going just being
transfixed by and and feeling feeling
like this is important I didn't know why
or what it was but I just had an
awareness like this is important well
you know how you said what you that
drive where your dad turns around your
mom turns around says this is people
your dad works with and every morning on
the way to church for me because my dad
was a preacher really no I didn't get
Kennison all those approved yeah yeah
but I didn't get I didn't I wasn't
allowed to watch anything so I didn't
discover that stuff until the 90s when I
started looking into doing stand-up and
persol with us yes yes are they forgiven
you haha each nice not when they see the
new our I'm working yes my favorite
jokes ever written Marie Bell renault
has in his act haven't you uh uh they
have it's funny you should mention that
I got a letter an email from my old
basically my old Sunday school teacher
not too long ago who found an old clip
of me do I used to do this bit about and
when I groped it i thought it was
amazing and now I've it's old and I
think maybe I wasn't the first person to
do that but I used to do a bit about uh
being that my dad was a preacher if I
was gay I date a black man just to make
sure the heart attack killed him and
that's up online and I can't get rid of
it or anything and it took in the woman
wrote me she's like hey Marie how are
you i've talked to swim in 20 years how
are you I just want to say oh I oh no
I'm gonna do I'm gonna read it on
another podcast so I was gonna dwell in
it it out right behind you but I gotta
do it for another podcast I got to save
it anyway I just got you i am thinking
I'm special you were dead wrong
everything you you are Adam Ferrara well
the guy you introduced yes I did we were
together did we bring up your name I was
sewing I don't think so we just started
no I think by the by the cadence of his
voice yes you should know this is adam
first so anyway so i didn't get into a
shame on you I didn't get into all that
Hicks and all that stuff till the 90s
man and then I was just that's like
mind-blowing happiness man he was once
you get into it you're just like yeah
and what are these guys all watch these
guys working yeah just I with Hicks I
was really yeah I'm guy I I host I was
hosting a governor's comedy club on Long
Island am I the only one club still left
right now though josh i left the door
open cuz i was hot today there's flies
in here yeah i like flies okay okay we
can have mine listen me oh I don't mom
oh yeah why was I was hosting the show
governors and Hicks was there and i did
a joke in the middle cuz you do you
would do 1015 up front then the middle
badges 20 you do five because be able to
get up and go to bed we that's when we
would do it five in the middle and you
bring up the headline so Hicks is there
and i did a joke i forget what joke it
was but he gave me a tag line he watched
me oh wow and he gave me a tag line
was I remember somebody dolphin I forget
what it was but he gave me a tag line
for the joke uh and I'm like holy [ __ ]
not only the bill Hicks watch my set but
he thought it was funny and tagged it
for me and I was I was a smoking
cigarette since we were outside we're
having a cigarette and you know picking
his brain like all the other comics cut
to a mountain la MTV half-hour comedy
hour is shooting out here and it was on
it for some reason was on the lot so I
was outside having a cigarette and Hicks
not only came up and remembered me
remembered the joke oh wow hey Adam how
are you man you still doing that bit the
tagline working for you and I'm like
it's like two years later and I was like
how cool is that yeah you know okay and
just just to be acknowledged by him sure
um how did he do that weekend he did one
of the front he died right again but
they don't they you know they don't they
didn't get it but I was sitting there
going this is [ __ ] genius yeah it's
like you know you you're watching you
listen to Mozart and you're going good
there's no cowbell you know what sake
and usually jazz I've always said it's
just like it's it's a thing that doesn't
work and stand up sometimes we're like
jazz is a thing you listen to it and
you're like this sucks then you see it
live and you go I get it and that was
something that didn't now it's almost
the reverse where people like I Drive
uber the amount of young people that get
into my cab and always go to Bill Hicks
as one of their favorites blows my mind
erase videos out now are like moving
people it's it's important ways were
when he like the bomb when he said we
got a bomb like a smart bomb I could
just direct to a house why can't we just
put food and people bananas mad and when
when he was called to testify for
watching porn mr. Hicks and beautiful i
love something and he did that Manny at
this show they subpoena me they subpoena
manages just watching him work is it's a
master class when I may or may not I may
or may not have been at a patriot
missile site last month when I was on my
tour of the Middle East and I've not had
done bill Hicks's bit about what's this
one do that yeah the military may or may
not have not liked it
well it's in some of them may or may not
really like I'm touching the buttons hey
is that the guy to marry the black man
just to kill his father was that crazy
thing to I got whatever I write with
people I was going to go well you can
attack the crowd and a lot alike even
like Carlin said you know make it about
we not you and I'm like you know who
didn't give a flying [ __ ] and was Bill
Hicks yeah he's like you're wrong and
let me tell you why yeah and that's what
made him before I would seem i remember
i saw him stand up New York when I was
the club in the city because i'm a Long
Island come i started on Long Island and
I didn't go into the city until I was
ready because really you could just stay
in work in Long Island well it was ya na
na dat you know why work as much as I
did at a car oh yeah that's why I had a
car and I had and my father instilled
responsible so I was always on time the
car was full of gas and it was clean
right so I knew well that I could drive
the headliners in New York cuz i was
working for a guy named John Schuler
when i first started used to book
connecticut all these shitty rooms in
connecticut they were barge there one
nighters but as when all the bar owners
found out that comedy was cheap to
produce so they would they paid you
right at a register yeah so all the the
New York comics that would work this the
barrooms didn't have cars so I would
pick him up I was on time and and then I
would drop him off but I wouldn't we'd
meet at the improv when he probably said
be on 41 so I pick him up at the improv
and I Drive him home and I go hey thank
you will you live I've got a car I'll
dry and I dropped my third door so they
would call up ago yeah I want to work
with adam and i had the stage time and i
learned i kept my mouth shut and I
learned watch these really good comments
just [ __ ] die because you're not
working it's not they would we call them
tonight show comics they were suit and
tie comics yeah they was setup punchline
segue setup punchline safeway you can't
do that at a [ __ ] ball oh yeah did it
and even on Long Island you got I'm very
animated and his voices and i'm using
the whole stage it's like it's like lion
tamer with a whip and chair okay it's
your attention and I'm gonna keep it
yeah you know and then the check spot
comes out and there's that famous story
of the and I forget her to comic words
the story's been told so many times
about shooting stars and Yonkers I don't
Lee I know it you don't story but i
might a story i don't know i forget who
the comic was on it but the way i heard
the stories is a guy on stage Late Show
Friday's shooting stars and Yonkers
right and he's he's on stage and he's
dying and he's looking at the crowd he
finally goes like basically you know I
don't care if you guys live I've done
this on TV I know it's funny and from
the back of the room you hear he's
wounded let's get up never show weakness
yeah speaking of weakness you have you
gotten in any fights lately for me I've
been clean I'm going like a different
direction guys you know I'm out of the
we just met see lose explain what ethic
Oh has a track record of getting a fight
rock record numbering jumped or being
escorted out of clubs and like a couple
years ago I got jumped in vegas and [ __ ]
and got into a ruckus their guy could
first I've ever had been jumped ever in
my life I've gotten close when it cuz i
started in the south i started like
Orlando so like I was doing Alabama
Louisiana Georgia verge every and bars
cuz i mean i got i was out of bed
drinking problems like i was on the move
really quick okay there the colors are
just beginning yeah i get jumped a lot
in the poor man well I have a bad
drinking problem I did I don't drink
anymore because I had to clean that [ __ ]
cuz it like it threw me into the dealy
cuz I was like working nothing but nice
clubs my drinking got in the way and
then the judge thought it was a good
idea if you stop right oh and you know a
couple of cement board about the drunk
comic getting demoted from the good
clubs to the bars to the bar scene maybe
not the best part for a truck well I say
is a thing about the road is and again
my father's voice my head to learn you
know learn from learn from your mistakes
yes we're smart man does wise may learn
from somebody else but I've seen a lot
of guys man just I'm telling you bottle
or end up at the end of a needle you
know yeah what's an easy job to do that
way cuz if it to you yeah it's you're
around it constantly and then you're in
a business where like you live and die
on each set the set goes bad where's the
bottle setting those good where's the
bar that's the one extra yeah when you
connect what you do to who you are
you're far [ __ ] everyone else like and
that's one of the lessons you had to I
had to learn sure is not to have your
identity wrapped up in in in the end it
which is tough I mean y'all true there's
a whole reason we're in this [ __ ]
businesses I know the instant
gratification and and the validation and
that that of that adrenaline rush when
you get the lads its own drug
yeah and it's why I remember when I
first my first acting gig my first
single camera acting gig without an
audience is your it is a single Cameron
I do do do the show ale and the joke and
the director goes great cut moving on
like that's it with whiskey applause yes
somebody seems to love me now i have
problem i need instant validation right
now somebody laugh applaud metal week
own award be our next fact has a void in
his life he fills with the adulation of
strangers please welcome to this junkie
himself I did the same thing at a small
part in a movie man and in the and I
laid the joke and it didn't land and i
literally just went what happened why do
i do right I was like I wasn't really
give ya these words work but yeah well
that's that's a hard thing man it's not
is is is and knowing how to separate
that or knowing that your first question
you have to separate I think isn't that
like the journey when people say there's
always a thing about 10 years in comedy
we're like it's you spend so much of
your time trying to make other people
laugh and other people validate you it
takes 10 years before you figure out
that you're like oh you shouldn't really
care that much and you should try to do
more of what like you want to do with
your time up there ya know while you
like it in a sense of like don't placate
to the crowd right the [ __ ] did you want
to talk about and make it funny and go
from there because i think my first you
want to talk about you also can figure
out what you want to say but that said
yes i'm saying is like it's finding
yourself of like what am i doing up here
and what do I wanted what do I want to
do with this I just seen your app you
out observational confession ah I do
like a lot of soon I mean I Bob well
it's like she what I can't understand
it's like you know like I do i do more
like like I get like social commentary I
talk well chunk of my axe is about
talking about my experience with mental
illness and my my times in mental wards
and shits you've been on the inside I've
been on the inside a few times my man
you just got out that's why I had them
yeah it's just like I need some daylight
you know can't leave right now no I'm
fascinated cuz I'm fighting this [ __ ]
every day you know you like you know
there's the I think I haven't figured
out you there's there's the creative
side I'm not manic depressive with is
that I get panic attacks sure you know I
was talking about that and trying to
deal with that and I it's I don't know
if its inherent to our personnel is why
we do what
we do arm because the amount of
depression I go through to get to the
the fork you think I I should be there
should be a lot more [ __ ] money
because it wasn't it the thing like I
mean this is just like a rough go I just
that's I was telling Marie is like my my
direction now is like I'm looking at
other forms because I've gotten clubs
that won't book me now because like at
the end of my act I tell like a story
about immortality about what life should
be and it's not funny and it's five
minutes and clubs are like I'm trying to
sell mozzarella sticks [ __ ] get out
of my club so I understand that so I
like now I've gotta like I just finished
and been working on tirelessly my like a
presentation a lecture that's I take my
stand up and I take my knowledge of what
I know of depression and what I've done
to like fight it and combat it no vomit
and what the causes are and put it into
an hour-long type of thing for colleges
and for other things you know the kind
of put and one man shows now so I went
through the same thing you did and i
boiled it down here's the thing Farid
Sun Tzu The Art of War know the terrain
you know the [ __ ] terrain I'm doing
my just know where and what you can get
away with I push the boundaries in clubs
now cuz i wrote my one-man show it's my
next special and there's a part about my
dad dying and just you have your your
little your instincts tell you when to
push him when to bring them back so why
bring them all the way down and i bring
them back but don't just keep a little
bits like chocolate mousse little bit is
just fine to make your point so and it
also helps you understand it for me
anyway i don't know about you I but it
helps you understand if you can if you
can explain it in a sentence then you
know you're talking about if it makes
you five [ __ ] minutes to make a point
it the idea is still out here you got to
bring it in you got to bring this I did
and I found this in my my third special
it's called funny as hell and my dad got
diagnosed with chemo he got diagnosed
with cancer we had to go to chemo so I
wrote a joke about chemo it's on YouTube
the chemo Joe and I bring them way down
about chemo and I bring them back up and
I get an applause break at the end
because you have to build that tension
into what you're saying because you and
then you have to give them the release
so don't be you can take them there
don't leave them there too long your
instincts will tell you how to bring
them out give them the release and then
it's going to be like a slingshot and
that's that slingshots going to be the
applause break and I it's called the
chemo bit and I
I finish my special Adair's and I get a
call from a professor I'm remember his
name he teaches for NYU NYU and Yale and
he asked if he could license license
that bit to teach you know the comedy
writing no interesting yeah i'll put
that chemo bid on the facebook page yeah
I'll get that interest on I'm expecting
his last name is Professor uh Eddie I
gotta remember his name and I apologize
that's right I'll trifle you remember
will say and if not i'll put it up on
the facebook page with the clip but
that's what I mean I tried to make the
point because it's what I wanted to say
cuz you gotta realize if you taken him
to a place they're not gonna laugh
you're kind of breaking the social
contract of the evening how many
specials have you done uh 3 i'm working
on my fourth oh really awesome well I
haven't I haven't done um a extensive
tour like I right now I have a couple
months out and rotamer looking for
tourists oh girl I've been working I've
been you know I've been i went from
rescue me when rescue me ended i got
another gig called top gear and shirt
was that the end of the end of rescue me
was the beginning of top gear so I
rolled right into that ice and then and
then while I was doing top guys doing
Nurse Jackie so one of those three
things coincide aware those tough course
been on forever how long yeah we did six
seasons wow that's great um rescue moves
for and and jackie was too so i haven't
been on the road as a full-blown comic
for a while so i know to get back to it
i am it's when you get away from it and
you come back to it it's a it's a it you
come at it with new energy and you can
add it with like when I when I look at
stuff now [ __ ] you know you'll do the
morning news and you'll find a clip and
I'm like oh I remember that job okay you
know I okay this but you come back word
because you've grown as you know as a
person the nice thing was I'm still want
to talk about the things I talk about so
it's like it's it's that's nice but you
did there's this fresh eyes and new
energy what uh where you headed off to
where am I going where are we now it's
like this is California oh we're in
California I'm going back to a new york
new york i got jersey i'm at stress
factory I like stress I'm Vinnie's joint
oh so as many uncle Benny great I'll
vineet of any Brando Oh Brando uh
somebody went at stress factory I'm
I got a Vegas state I might like tour
schedule is all right I know I got
towards it a performing arts center in
Pennsylvania doing a casino in Saratoga
so you know it's like like you're
talking about know the environment like
I want to do work on my special and it
does have emotional changes to it it
does tell a story there's a narrative in
it I'm not doing that late show friday
in jersey but i'm not risking a door
doing 45 minutes and i'm just gonna stay
on top of you keep dancing don't get
time to breathe deep kids i do you know
what happened do you have the story on
what happened to rascals and orange the
brothers yeah uh I know they license out
those Rascals Comedy Hour in the
eighties with my mullet you know that
pissed me off no I assume they went out
of business I thought I heard they went
out of questionable bookkeeping I'm
stunned that's all I was like don't
worry about the accounting but don't add
up that's why we do it in pencil that's
all I was looking for so i have so many
clubs were there out in when i started
you were going when i started on Long
Island um there was a site comedy club
haha there was chuckles in mineola o our
honda of mineola near honda video there
was that governor's which is still there
the brokerage which is still there and
it was a place out way out east coke on
come a comedy club uh that was wedding
Lake Ronkonkoma oh right my and then
they had the bars we used to do we do
you know cinnamons and there was called
top of the town you know I wouldn't do
but your bar set it at me eleven o'clock
my friendship my buddy Chris franjola is
from Lake Ronkonkoma there's no click
one konkana comic ronkonkoma ronkonkoma
can ever say that it was it was the
conch of a comedy club and they spelled
it all with k's i'm like the KKK I
didn't see they think that well with the
comedy rule of threes and yeah kazar
funny the KKK should be hilarious it
makes sense it makes good sense what
kind of shady uh what kind of shady
characters love watches back then I know
that up in Jersey a bunch of them um
you'd hear stuff like it all these clubs
like he you funny stick around we're not
gonna pay tube and um but there was one
got packing out this is story by the
you're packing out the cigarette machine
mm-hmm
comic goes to get paid he was like look
I know your money or funny guy he's
backing out the cigarette machines we do
as well as we like to his fifty bucks
and what do you smoke haha i remember at
the end at the end of it like at the end
of the 80s when i was a kid once heard
falling apart yeah grum at like 90 early
90s i think it was in the comic club
owners would come to you i get paid in
green and white oh really yeah i'll take
the grain yeah cash yeah I can buy my
own yeah yeah I was like in right and I
was never really you know I was never
really thank God I didn't have that if
then go to statement in my head right so
run but yeah you can like you say you
had to be careful out there because it's
the lifestyle is conducive to will give
it to you drink for free yeah you know
now it wasn't like in the 80s to is that
it was I was at the very end you're
right is the end of the vessel very i
started in 88 when I say start I'm I
just wanted open mics mm-hmm for like
six eight months and then then I got an
agent then I started working I would I
had a day job you get an agent inside of
a year is I did well I got lucky cuz
they saw me at the club was the guy that
booked the club he was there so I got
and you know and I was cheap and I had a
car so and and reliable yeah so I would
show up and it was it was a job to me I
was very serious i still am to the point
where i got notebooks of [ __ ] that I'm
never gonna see the light of day uh you
ever lose your notebook look I got tons
of how many want I got him all over I
lost my notebook like I don't know six
months ago and I was just like oh man I
hope my name's not in that yes cuz you
fight you i don't people find an issue i
had it happen in bed flappers of Burbank
where they're just like hey Ian we have
your notebook in my head we know what
yours we saw the skulls and cross
because no matter what i can put notes
all day on my iphone but they're just
like i'll write this out full form a
little more a little more for me yeah
didn't know i look i have to start with
my notebook i just thought and i have no
sir i have a cheap fountain pen and i
have the notebooks i like because it's
like that's it just connects to me that
way so i'll write it and then when i
start working on and I gotta move this
here so I've got a lot of arrows that I
don't like the computer but it is
convenient but I don't like typing on
the same way this guy sounds stupid but
I lose this feeling yes
match to it you know there's two there's
a defense she didn't have an iPad you
had to swipe right let's make an art
yeah yeah it's true there is something
she's like there's no books under my
thing we're like I've got some of those
like five those need five I will hand it
for three it's full I'm scared can I go
back and look at it right now I think
I've got so much going on I'm just like
one day I'm gonna crack that bad boy
back open cuz you know there's like a
good four or five ideas that you're just
like I never put this on stage and this
is a good idea but Bill Clinton is not
an office anymore no no but no there's
always hostess always those jokes you're
just like oh [ __ ] i never did this and
he's a good idea that's why it's the
second side of this book it's the whole
story the quantity and quality story not
the guy you get they give you 50 pounds
of clay and they split up the people's
election you make as many pots as you
can and you'll be judged on how many you
make and you make one perfect pot and
the people who just kept making the pots
won both you won because you've made
that you made so many that you keep
doing it and doing it and doing it
started everyone is perfect so you keep
doing it one's gonna be perfect you got
a lot of [ __ ] yeah second hot water I
don't use that but it's like it does man
yeah infinite monkeys if you put an
infinite amount of monkeys in front of
an infinite amount of uh typewriters
they'll eventually type Shakespeare
really nothing I should [ __ ] good
showdown minutes on [ __ ] mental
illness and I shut the show down on mega
with infinite monkeys typewriters and
like all these monkeys kick it around in
the mic and for the glitch dicks I'm
thinking how they gonna hit the space
boy over thumb is I just they just use
that one big if you teach what is the
word a prehensile tail so they'll do
points poop poop poop eventually all
right I've never heard that monkey which
are like that I love that uh so what do
you think's changed since when you
started and when where it's at now the
best thing for me is is the way i can
record my sets now I said that's like I
gotta renekton of those did I was little
all right a little first I had those
little little micro cassettes then they
saw
and I found a small one with a with a
big cassette because I could play it in
a car oh right away helmet but the sound
was so [ __ ] off yeah now I got a
great I got a great and uh app it's I
talk because it has a big timer on it I
talk are you said Const arrest ever
after yeah it's better you can hang it
on stage so now I take their points when
can I put it right on stage I used to
like the mini discs cuz you know what
you attract mark in the mini disc zone
right back to a joke and all day cuz
when you're on the road you just focused
on work and you know do you press in the
morning you go back you take your nap
call my wife tell her i love i get up go
to the gym and then my headphones were
in all day listening to the acting to
you to take advantage of the stage time
so i put the track marks in just go to
that one section just push the button
man mini discs i had the cassette
recorder that was the size of a cassette
yeah yeah you know and had the red
button for record and I remember I must
have told the story a thousand times on
the show but send to the back of the lap
back with me and my buddy Chris franjola
but just from blank ronkonkoma and we're
in the back and we're watching this guy
just eat it on stage man just eat it how
this guy blows this guy's never I can't
believe they're leavin letting him on
he's never gonna last this guy sucks you
want to get out here yeah let's go don't
forget your recorder that's not mine hey
rewind rewind occur that's funny okay is
there not something beautiful going to
like open mics and watching them suck
like I find that there's something so
like get connects me back to that the
open mic days when you go to like
certain shows and there's like new
people or something and they're like
sweating and they're always too nervous
where there's something like really like
a nice man she met the other nervous and
like they're sweating their tribal heart
Santigold oh my god relax I just really
why just I suck relax there's this guy's
like last week and he was pacing around
and he goes i'ma what's up man he goes
to my first time I make here's the
important thing this doesn't matter yeah
that's all you got to remember going up
this doesn't matter whether those people
like you or don't they'll forget about
it tomorrow yeah so just go up and I can
do the [ __ ] you did and just really try
to like enjoy the moment yes that's all
you really can doing this because this
is like if you keep with this you're
just gonna have a thousands of these
moments well that's because you
I think I would going back to what we
were saying before our value is
connected and how well we do you know
your actual [ __ ] identities connected
on how well you do yeah where were you
when you first starting out you have a
shitty set I mean you just can't I was a
mess and you have got to get back on
stage idea it's like getting hit with a
pitch if anybody play ball the next time
you get up to that that plate the only
thing you're thinking of is I hope I
don't get hit with a [ __ ] ball that's
what's in your head and that's what I
think comedy is like when you have that
bad show you like you've got to get back
up even when you're having a bad set
you'll go longer cuz you're like oh no
I'm not leaving with this yeah yeah yeah
I've seen pros long-standing guys I'll
put the name out later that went far and
beyond their headline set and they
caught a little bit of like okay get off
stage you bday 34 years and he's like no
no I'm not there yet and kept going and
going and going I was like blown away
skylight I really like and really
respect i wanna be like dude come on you
gotta gotta pull er break me I want to
shake it off you know it's like it's it
the trick is not to get get caught in
that trap well does it being get caught
you don't learn that for a while you
know yeah yeah that is a tough thing so
I can learn I'm Jen I would have to
drive home after cuz i was driving these
gigs so i have to drive home after a
lousy set in a bar you know but having i
haven't figured out that you know a
statement of fact is not a personal
short coming oh I'm sorry I couldn't get
the attention of these drunks during the
playoffs at a bar in Connecticut it's my
fault i suck you know but you don't know
that so I'm trying to make the toll
taker laughs six bucks dogs are funny
you know just trying to get shake it off
somehow god I was you know you talk
about football I was in Daytona Beach
this [ __ ] room and they had it was
impossible to see the stage so they had
TVs and then a big not like big screen
behind you right the guy was from mass
right and the [ __ ] the Patriots were
in the playoffs right the game was on
I'm about to go up on stage he goes look
Pat's in the [ __ ] playoffs bro I'm
not turning off the football game for
anybody it's like nobody can see so I
had to go up and do stand-up while the
football game was being played on every
single TV and people just like cheer
intimately in a set up because what
pages guy you just like real
dude really well didn't just pay me my
money and let me go back to my room yes
this makes zero sense of Richard or at a
point I would have been like give me
half and I'll yeah let's call this is
not yeah let's call it even you save
half i'll say well i'll take home half
let's get out of here i just i did a one
of our gigs i did there was a Papa
Schadt basketball game the little next
stage and the guy didn't turn it off I
was at halfway through the half way thru
my set I just I put the mic stand
erstand I went up and I started playing
defense [ __ ] good blogging sharkskin
shot those I never did I got I grew up
in Jersey but I moved out here basically
my whole adult life so I started
stand-up out here I so I never really
were I did stand-up New York and
Caroline's and all that stuff but I
never really got into the new york uh
bar scene i did my bar scene out here in
pacific northwest so but i just gotta
figure that was just it ten times more
intense than a Pacific Northwest bar gig
just from growing up in Jersey yes we
know how many people it is I mean in the
Long Islanders I knew but but you I am
that person so I know what that's like
you know I'm not gonna I'm gonna bring
that energy to Pacific Northwest ago hey
you guys are damped and caffeined up I'm
just gonna be you're gonna be who you
are in that environment so it's
definitely definitely more aggressive
yeah I think that's what dismissive I
think it's missive well dismissive where
you got in the Pacific Northwest oh yeah
yeah yeah this is aggressive yeah like
originally from Tennessee but I did
junior high school and junior high all
through your size never really a jersey
I don't have that jersey aggressive
thing going so I think I nice thing
about growing up on east coast in New
York where I'm from and you know being
in that environment but you're never
gonna look those people go I wonder
what's on their mind [ __ ] tell you
yeah we're here everybody wears a smile
but you ripped that skin off and
everybody's ready to snap a [ __ ]
minute snap at any minute yeah they were
all full of [ __ ] that's why I like
you're just like you've got two of the
biggest comedy cities in the world
between LA and New York and I find them
so like polar opposite and how they kind
of run in everything now in a sense of
like I never thought I'd see ageism
stand up comedy and it does exist out
here you know which every tues that'll
exists at it's show business or she'll
be this thing as I hope you have to
finish overhears [ __ ] show business
sunday an umbrella comedy scene in there
it's it's it's still shot but it's more
comedy he'll probably be it's uh it's
it's a little more this is why we've
come here you know when I can't when I
first came out I was a comic when I came
I came out with a TV deal but I was a
comic how long ago was that I came out
in 93 oh wow so the five years after you
started you at no lie I got I got I got
a I got a TV deal I moved out here and
there was a bunch of [ __ ] actors who
had this six minutes cuz we were hot
comics were hot oh yeah I do so I was
like I don't never seen this guy in a
road and that he's too [ __ ] handsome
to be a comic with his life um but they
were actors that were just putting
together their [ __ ] to get noticed
you know and when I come on island I
mean now it's the YouTube people that
can't that sell out a comedy club but
they don't win at right right when I was
starting it was the soap opera people
really were you and stana what Willie
was a so powerfully still does it he
does yeah but he doesn't have an act he
never had a knack we started I have
never heard this in my life the soap
opera guys figured out they could sell
out a comedy club in a comedy club guys
were willing to have it so I her a call
and say listen you want open for Willie
yeah okay cuz you know you're gonna get
back room okay good do 45 what cuz he
doesn't have an act he goes up for five
minutes they go crazy he tells one story
that's not funny they realized there's
nothing man and then he signs pictures
oh wow but he'll sell out your time to
see him and that's what YouTube is doing
right now I've said this before I get
bumped I got bumped by a girl who plays
dirty songs on the ukulele she's 23
years old yes and she pass he'll pack
out senior there vine at once I haven't
seen her back there and I don't want to
I don't know who she is and she baby
she's hilarious I don't know but she's
23 and writes dirty songs on ukulele
I've seen GI got bumped once I haven't
seen her back since well you're
basically the art form I think it's not
really respect we're talking mimes
pretty much and I will strippers with
our clothes on it right it's like this
is the arena using no clothes yeah yeah
we're emotional strippers here's my pain
give me a you have some of your pain to
let's do this all right there are that
thing of people jumping into the club
like just like five years ago you
started seeing anybody that came from
improv started jumping into the stand-up
scene and I'm like you guys got to be
careful because you're going to sell out
and if you don't have a solid hour
you're not going to you're not gonna
come back because everybody's gonna come
see you you're not gonna be like it
because you can't get good at this in a
year even though you come from that
background and you're gonna see and I
was like I spent it was a weird thing
it's just like it all exploded and next
thing you know I started getting calls
from clubs leg hey Ian can you come in
because we might have to switch you I'm
like what's going on and I'm like
so-and-so from SNL is kind just like
what why and then going and just
watching that so-and-so is yes you do
yes I do Doug but and it's just like it
just became a train wreck show and the
way they had to run the show became
weird and then people are like yelling
at me at the end of the show being like
that guy sucked and I'm like look at you
walk into a club and spend 50 bucks to
see this dude you saw him what more do
you want did you look like this guy's
your favorite stand-up comic no cuz you
know he doesn't do stand-up you know
where celebrity culture you saw the
celebrity they don't know cannulation I
think so you think it's basically a hose
job peep knowledge up they just know
okay he'll be funny they know I'm the
ones like people come to see me I have
the people that know me from stand-up
common that the hardcore fans and I love
to see him they still like we've had
your special when you had your mullet to
you wanna hear ya and i love that that
they that they still come to see but i
get people to come see me from top gear
and nurse jackie know like I didn't know
you were stand up I was like what did
you think was gonna happen burnouts in
the parking lot drop a transmission said
yeah thank you change your lusting mean
humming but they go you're really funny
we even know you were staying up and
it's nice to you have that that's the
nice thing is you your background is
stand up so like when you compile
anything that's what like a lot of
people do is like get good at stand up
go get your [ __ ] on TV or whatever and
then when they come to see you you've
got that Vinny TV van de the map has
changed it used to be and that this
change with me too because it used to be
the older guys would tell me how you do
it tonight you used to get a career no I
you know now I did it tonight show I did
a letter minute I'm like okay Monday get
back up on a horse
the break ain't happening stereo so it's
like you don't even need TV it's like
you know you're on TV should people see
you it's so it's so diluted our craft is
so deluded because the places we go is
it's primarily a business so if you can
sell that that night out you will
there's a show there it says comedy club
is there's the you in further it's going
to be funny but it could be an actor it
could be done to person it could be you
know whoever it is but it's like the
it's still a business first so they got
put asses in the city i right when i
first started out John Mendoza just said
yeah but the tonight show on your resume
nobody's gonna check I remember when I
started like in all these like see rooms
and there'd be like weekend rooms in
some [ __ ] hotel and I like trying to
push for headliner and they'd be like
where's the TV credit i'm like i needed
a credit to play this [ __ ] hole that
pays a hundred need to put all their
[ __ ] pasta yeah it's just like put
down whatever put down NBC just put on a
network that's what i would do i bill
I've seen on CBS and Fox here you go
have fun like nobody you know an Oscar
winner yeah I always like when uh those
actors turned coming over because I
always like when they're intro is seen
him on NCIS Miami oh they must be
hilarious it's gotta be good this guy
knows his way around a fake crime scene
offense i love you on order thank you
yeah I remember him from das boot are
good German submarine operator yes low
ship what's your favorite place to play
what area went to winter in this country
um I I do like the Pacific Northwest
okay like that what I love the air
because I was talking before we turn the
mics on before I had no intro sorry let
me pull my own string Chatty Cathy doll
but between we talk about LA and New
York I'm a better comic in New York
because it's more stage time now is more
stage time and there's more to draw from
you know there's more it is more
inspiration and it's more energy it's
like you know you're gonna go down a
seller on a weeknight you get 20 minutes
sure really 20 minutes and about 15
we're used to be when I was 15 I'm still
I mean just but he even the weekend
spots are cut down no it's so even if
you're working on something it's not
like I'm doing a full 45 to an hour on
the road right build the hammock spot
well like I'll get him on my side I'll
introduce the idea then then I'll play
for five minutes before the check spot
comes out and I got to bring them you
know you got a bang so it makes the
material for me it makes it work better
because it's got to be good quick yes
i'll get i'll get like admitted to to
warm up then steer them where I wanted
to go try the new bit and then get away
out yeah I'm only doing that in the city
so if the process becomes quicker yeah
so so I feel always feel like I write
more in New York because my my stuff
isn't setup Segway punchline you know
there's act outs in it and sure you know
it's kind of animated so the ideas grow
like I would start i remember when i was
a kid I'd go into the city and I would
start on the Upper West Side I would
park park my car on seventy-second 72nd
Broadway was state of New York yeah and
I would start the upper west side and i
would start there and work we're way
down to the cellar but i would leave the
car because I take a cab because it was
quicker right a pocket so I lived the
car and I would just camp my way down
stop at carolines I would stop at Gotham
when Gotham was on 22nd and then hit my
way down to the cellar go to Boston
comma club in the cellar and I would
have the ID the framework of a bit by
the time I finished it oh wow that's
great so much that you get four or five
spots that way you okay great well
that's a good thing about New York as
opposed to hear is I said this before I
got a spot at the ice house one night
and a spot at the Melrose improv three
years ago i'm still talking about it
like it's a yeah I mean more than one
spot in town yeah that was yeah and
understand that those two spots round
trip to get from your house to Pasadena
to the Melrose and back to your place is
a good six seven like it's a day trip
yeah totally yeah get number one even
though you left at five right how many
of what's who holds the record in New
York for most spots I don't even know
it's steve byrne and you went up there
and did a documentary about it oh yeah
Wow listen if somebody had done like I
mean it was well over a
really I guy he had done and then he
went show documentary about going and
breaking the record cuz i think burn
started there if i'm not mistaken don't
hold me to that but yeah so he went shot
a whole documentary about doing like I
don't know 13 14 15 show I remember when
Jerry was shooting the comedian movie
brought me three times in one week
really about me twice the cell and bump
me at the at Gotham and I here maybe
said Adam I'm sorry I said this [ __ ]
movie better be funny right now to
pissing me off just bumped you off for
the night no no just yet what happened
it would shoot and you know it was it
was cool i remember the cameras were
small never talking to the camera guys
mean so cool they come in set up real
quick he'd go up like we set up the guys
walked in and they would hold it you
know you're still documentaries yeah was
all that stuff but it was uh but yes
also want an answer to your question
it's it's uh it's the city new york city
i write like a better yeah that a comic
and it's and i get i admit i get lazy
when i'm home because i don't have to i
can just talk to these people because i
know that i can talk about dairy barn
right which is a drive-through [ __ ]
delhi and making everyone's had that
experience so i can mind that sometimes
i'll do a little a little sleight of
hand like I'll get a joke that might fit
in there and I'll put it in the context
of dairy barn just to see if I could
make that little that that little scene
i'm playing out work and see if that
joke works and then sometimes it's it's
it's it's like a host organ i can get
that wrong so I did a lot like I'll get
a host organ idea and I'll take a joke
out of it and see right I want to fit it
and and and that that's a nice nice nice
little trick to have to create something
about Ian Ian from Florida so a dairy
mart is out there called dairy barn
derry by from there like a drive-through
liquor store dr. benattia her eyes
resting
read glad they didn't have those it
floated by the way because that's the
last thing any red barn you would drive
through and tell them what you want
their bring it into your car and then
that you would pay for it they would
tell you the total and you would yell
out you would yell it out like I it's
1496 out of 20 so they have to go back
to make the change and they bring hat
back T and you were a kid you always
wanted the cookies and get cigarettes
and booze and not to get out of your car
but it's like that i mean i could talk
about that about like you know the old
amusement park that i would that we went
through that everybody knows you're
awful stuff yeah so when I come home I
can do that right home but I like
working there like a San Francisco I
always get a good vibe Chicago's great i
love you i love work in chicago the
improv in chicago is one away I it's one
of my favorite clubs yeah I love Tony
grabs tony's awesome i love tony i set
up back with him and florida to the the
improv of my friends on the radio Paul
and Ron on the radio Florida improv I
like oh that the Lauderdale improv is
great that's the hard rock I had I was
there about month man I i we had a
hundred and twenty people talking in the
back and I didn't say it was easy I said
would that is not an easy room Renee is
it's not like the people are so nice and
once you get them they're so cool crack
them yeah you know that that's one of
the things about to command their
attention if that's the one thing that
i'm i'm playing with now when i do when
i do the next special there's the
emotional parts of them so i gotta beat
the SH and it's built the rhythm of it
is built where I'm beating you up for 20
minutes I don't know I'm beating you up
with I'm not gonna let you breathe for
20 mins because I want you to rest when
I want you to pay attention oh the meter
is for 20 minutes and then then it slows
that doesn't stop it slows down and then
before they know it I'm talking my dad's
saying goodbye because he's in the
hospital room he knows he's going to die
and i buy that piece then I build that
tension I released him and then I got to
bring him right out of it again so it's
built that way so it's like a built on
trust me in the first five minutes rob
bartlett who is a comic who was on Imus
in the Morning for years and I was in
his first improv group and he told me
something I still numb to this day goes
in your first five first few jokes don't
get him to land get him to trust you
that's what you need to do once they
trust you you can take them any way you
want to learn and go really yeah I said
because I I've always played the get him
to
trust you with a laugh well no I'm sorry
I didn't mean like don't focus on don't
focus on just getting the left make the
left have trust in there no it's not i'm
not saying go up there and go listen
I'll lend you money you know I'm just
saying why are you also a prion look for
the trust I'll keep your secret no but
that that's what i meant i agree one
hundred percent that's like the guys who
go up there just I've seen so many
people launch into material like
straight off the bat in a ruckus room
left Fort Lauderdale and just starting
to material in common with that high
energy and it's usually I know what
you're thinking is a premise I don't
like you know blah Blee blah yeah but
those rooms down there Arthur
neighborhood when they built that big
room I remember when I was like what
well right before they built that I was
like middling a lot and loving it and
then when she said you were a hammock
you can't seem to you know that I
spotting you yeah and then I started
then she start bringing me in for when
they had like corporate and or sunday
shows my god I worked my ass off on
those cuz it was just like especially in
that room where they're used to see in
[ __ ] monster names and should tell
and I'm some schlub and if I can dress
her that hardly fits me perfectly it's
like okay so this room isn't gonna just
cuz it's an improv like I'm gonna go up
in just hammered because they're just
gonna hand me them now you guys it's it
so where's a good room 2 and I like
healing my life feeling that filter
they're building that brand all over the
yeah yeah hey did you ever do miami the
miami umbra I did it when it used to be
at the at the at the movie theater one
was upstairs oh I don't know that I did
it when I was upstairs first time I go
to Miami Elian Gonzalez so there's my
first 10 minutes i right second time i
go to they shot versace ok there's my
next 10 minutes then they asked me if I
want to come back I go you know [ __ ]
always happens when I come see you guys
then they moved it to Coconut Grove we
come out on behind ya boy come out you
come out through the wall yeah that's
the last time we there but I was years
ago fine getting trouble down there mmm
no I never really did anything i'll tell
you when i got i got uh I got in trouble
for doing a joke I think it where I was
um I might have been oh it wasn't
villanova that was they got mad at me
through the Catholics get mad at me Oh
villanova I get attacked by played
Villanova and I got mad cuz I put me on
state for some reason i was on a stage
there was a giant
kathak haces giant cross behind the
stage so whoever was opening up at a
radio guy whoever brought me up I'm I
said thank you so much i looked at the
cross that you said you guys have a huge
vampire problem so much people to back
it out um i got trolled i really
appreciate that joke yes so I got a
religion guys did Joe Paterno here the
what I got in trouble for Joe Paterno Oh
what is that is he uh people thought
when he took his statue down people
thought that you know they were no
outrage because he thought Joe Paterno
was a saint he turned his back on the
molestation of children it doesn't make
you a saint that makes you a pope great
joke so a great before you got on the
Catholic thing you got in trouble where
you say you're gonna bring I know those
jokes got me so I figure what a [ __ ] i
was but yeah but i'm trying to think
where I was I don't know I up look I'm
uh I'm not in fist fights like the guy
to my left I know don't worry about it I
don't leave that's a thing just like I
don't be thinkin like I'm just some like
instigator on stage or anything I'm not
you know thing ian is the most goofy
late your first of all very intimidating
looking that's why I'm saying but you
really gotta piss somebody off your over
six feet but he's goofy on stage using
wears a t-shirt with kermit the frog on
it he did a joke about a a chicken
farting out eggs onto a plate for
breakfast like goofy stuff show like the
fact that he gets into fights is
hilarious yeah we have a question that
we ask everybody on here when they come
over actually to we the first one is
heavier have you ever had any throwing
anything thrown at you know really 12 30
ice someone threw ice at me awesome yeah
ice at a bar in Connecticut um I'm gonna
say said the word yeah I forget you I
had ice ice ice yet what would set him
off connect I don't remember I just
remember like is that a fair be nice I
remember I was like really a Catholic
joke yeah not exactly Bennett Joker's
wild was the name of the club Oh
Connecticut it was like a boorish kind
of club ice flew at me in Friday night
yes so I'm gonna go yes all right go
with ice nice is good this is good and
the other one and a listener asked if
we'd ask this question more is when do
you what is the first time you remember
making somebody laugh I don't remember
but I remember my
family talking about it oh ro
interesting yeah I was I was a baby and
I was staying my I know where my plans
were gonna go my Uncle Frank my god
father was watching me Uncle Frank Matt
marry me and watching me and they put me
in the car seat arm and they tell the
story they looked in the mirror and I
was in the back of the car seat Nicole
Adam what's in your mouth and I went my
teeth and that was the thanksgiving
story you know for the next 20 years
that was it [ __ ] we and we laughed okay
fine ooh yeah we knew right then we knew
then yeah so we have we get a house no I
never got that laughs but I knew that I
I don't record I knew that that was the
first time no no awesome but I remember
it was a coveted thing in my
neighborhood to make the other guy
laughs to make people laugh cuz we can
have anything we just hang out you know
them and watch TV listen radio just make
each other laugh yeah but I and when I
realize I could do it I realize because
my fault my father's my hero he was like
but he would always come home ways work
at his ass off and just trying to put
food on the table and keep the [ __ ]
lights on and take care of everybody and
you could see the stress my mother to my
mother work together stress and
attention when I made him laugh it went
away right so like I saw him smile and
my father had a laugh that would fill a
room I mean jesse was his big guy and
everyone loved them so when he left it
was infectious so I I don't know if I
consciously was aware of this is what I
can do but I'm like well this is how I
can contribute i can i can try and take
that away from him right right you know
i just knew it felt good to make him
laugh Oh awesome that's a great story
like that i just realized i apologize i
left my eye I just got braces six months
ago so I'm still getting anything but I
left leg last things have been how is
doing the whole time I love it yeah yeah
he's not your smash I'm so glad the only
fifth of bourbon you're hitting I'm just
waiting for me by notch come on for our
okay i'm still waiting for marie do a
smokiness bring the lagavulin I'm
waiting for him to get like the
schoolgirl outfit that goes with those
bracelets
apologize i only have one high sock
here's a fine i bought clippers and
convince my wife to cut my hair so now
my wife cuts my hair and I braces I'm
like a 9 year old he was she cuts your
hair a bug clippers and said babe I want
you to say listen I watched the woman
cut my hair 20 years right I paid her
the same amount and I'm like bye-bye
Clippers for 45 bucks this thing will
pay for itself and two haircuts Wow and
so I bought him I gave my wife the
instructions I'm like read this over
next monday or cutting my hair and she
did it she loves it it's fine you can't
[ __ ] this up it's true it's gorgeous
hair difference between a good haircut a
bad haircut forty dollars about a week
by week all right before we get out of
here off the top of your head worst gig
ever uh worst gig ever opening for
opening for mirror stars they called it
at UConn it was a lip-sync contest and
they were booing me and cheering
everybody else and I'm like them they're
not doing anything I'm the one actually
trying to do something they miss it's
not them saying they hated me uh yeah
opening for bands is bad too yeah that's
a rough I actually got away with a
Lionel Richie at the Greek Theatre [ __ ]
yeah yeah right here I was so cool i was
already theater i was a kid and I
remember i was i got a call arm and i
had just opened the night before for
what I forget one of the judge at a
performing arts center why did let's
call Winona the wind adams the big
bigger one the big girl whatever windows
Lisa I don't know why we I don't but I
went but it would but she she was born
against you had to be clean so I was I
was a kid I was clean i did a half hour
and I went home and I was drinking into
so sad oh yeah it was performing arts
idiot walking door hi yeah that's all
keep their attention yeah you know I was
nice so I went home I had a couple of
drinks i was sleeping and the phone rang
and it was my agent um and uh hello Rick
what because you want to work tonight as
you want open for Lionel Richie a go not
especially yes if you do they just fired
the comic they had
and they're scrambling to look for
someone get a cup of coffee the torments
going to call you in 10 minutes is okay
and I remember because it was it was
during a Clinton because was oh he did a
Monica Lewinsky joke and they wanted
everything clean so I guess he did a
[ __ ] joke I don't know it was but
they fired so uh and they called me up
and the the tormentors real nervous you
know he's like oh listen you came
recommended from our other manager who
did Wynonna um I just want you to not
together you could tell he's eager you
know why don't you he goes it but it's
always it's it's not a clean audience is
the Greek Theatre we just need you to do
you know 15 minutes just to keep their
tag I look I wear a suit I'm cute I'm
young I won't say [ __ ] perfect and they
always got they always do this and fit
works out you know we'll take you on the
road they're never taken you on the
[ __ ] Road that's the whole team at
that's the carrot they dangle and funny
I knew it then I go who you [ __ ] i
right yeah you're gonna take me to
Tuskegee when Lionel goes home so I went
I did it just to play to Greek Theatre
cuz you knew you were gonna suck they
don't want to see your annoying them
they don't want to see you you know but
it was the Greek Theatre how many times
am I gonna get that up and right so I
wanted to play degree so the Sun was
setting it was [ __ ] beautiful I went
on stage so there's no roof it's an
amphitheater so do you don't know if
you're doing good it's raining these two
people with umbrellas nobody there and
they're all waiting for Lionel come in
that's why i went up i did my set I
don't know how I did I just got through
it I and I walk off stage Sheila he was
in the band oh cool and the whole band
was on the side of the stage and and one
of the best giant bass player looked
amigos you did great usually we stay in
here just to watch [ __ ] die
who's that are gonna make the band
laughs man yeah are you dad you just
calm but you can't make a bad lip and
when I would never did tonight you
looked over my head who said who's the
guy sings Jesse girl rich bring drinks
free okay so Rick Springfield he punched
you should know but this almost was
gonna be worse than a punch I was
working some [ __ ] casino gig and the
next night I had done my show and Rick
Springfield was coming in that night I
get a call back at my hotel room lately
Ian Rick's not gonna make it we need you
to do the show I'm like for who I'm like
for their audience oh god I'm like
you're sending me to a death sentence
know like will pay 600 bucks like I can
do it so I get there and I'm eating my
meal like it's my like I was eating like
it was like my last meal because I
notice about them like it's going to be
80 year old people being like who the
[ __ ] is this guy we don't know who he is
and he doesn't play musical see just
like five minutes and I swear to god
they're like okay ten minutes we're
starting the show and I'm like this is
gonna [ __ ] sock this is gonna be
awful and then the doors break open and
there's this glorious looking man Rick
Springfield were there just walk Mike
thank God dude because I was so close to
other dog I thought there was no hope
for me yeah dead matter how funny it was
how good I was the thing was I was never
going to be Rick Springfield that's the
only thing they knew oh yeah i was doing
by the way you should never ever forget
that guy's name again yeah he saved your
ass yes he shaved your head Jessie
sterling Springfield y ungrateful piece
Kubrick Rick Springfield remember that
tattoo the ginger and neck if you have
to I did a kissy I did new years of the
casino and Tony Orlando was there nice
before so it's uh I or he was there
tonight after I've I'm having dinner I I
had not done my or I had just done my
show and for some reason I was we were
having always after show I was I was
having dinner at the show in the
restaurant so you're in the steak house
you know you're sitting there my I'm
there my wife was there and Richie
Minervini who owned the east side comedy
club and gave us all he's the Godfather
Long Island gravity and I brought him he
opened for me so we're all sitting him
Richie me and my wife I haven't dinner
and his kindness in this Yankees hat
keeps looking over at the table okay my
wife excuse himself hits up close to the
bathroom I water table I got Ritchie I'm
have to straighten this guy out he's
trying to pick up my [ __ ] wife away
he's like schmuck he's looking at you
that's Tony Orlando you're both on the
bill he's getting your attention he was
just go over and say hello to the man
show you respect them again [ __ ] i went
over i show my respect and my wife came
back and everything and mr. loves all
your funny show is very kind to me took
a picture and everything all right and I
and I and I said Richie you know and I
was wrong he was trying to pick up my
wife look at my gorgeous he was watching
who else did you open for this is great
um music wise Judd
there wasn't a lot those those two I
remember the Lionel Richie was was was
like the big one yeah Jayd him because
it was the no you couldn't leave i'll
tell you what happens like he walked by
I didn't know you weren't supposed to
talk to me is one of those guys I
remember I was just hanging around
backstage he was walking on stage and as
he walked by swing hello now you can't
talk to him you can't so probably
because of that yeah because I'm an
idiot um I open for who else today oh
yeah I can't my those those are the two
big ones oh you're gonna talk about as
the worst gig is opening for bands yeah
I guess they do that they bring in
comics cuz it's cheap set up you don't
worry about bringing there's no setup
grab my can go right there's no
competition yeah there's your own Foo
Fighters blowing the new band off stage
you know I yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
not it's and it's usually you know it's
usually older acts to you're not gonna
get ya although Kanye's not bringing a
comic tool brought uh stop it I'll have
to have greg behrendt tell the story
when he's on here great I'm Greg Barrett
it was Greg and I think David Cross were
doing a sketch before tool that's that's
cool and that's really cool they just he
said it was just rained with beer cans
many cups and lemons and just for 15
minutes don't want to see your annoying
especially a band like tool where that
the lead singer goes out of his way to
[ __ ] with crowds and [ __ ] like he'll
send he'll sing a whole a concert with
his back to the crowd like he does not
give a [ __ ] so I putting up a sketch
comedy thing for him is just like this
is [ __ ] sorry for my show and if you
have to pay attention she know you guys
like the year we need a location into
occupation give me a president and
something you eat for dinner look we can
we do this a quickie you'll see Slipknot
all right guy I Adam I want to thank you
for coming on tonight it's uh friend you
to me this is a long time coming so I
appreciate it thanks for i didn't
realize you live so close by the way
we're in the we're in the Marvis two
studios tonight we're not recording a
meal thinks comedy this is why i keep
this one going for this Westsiders don't
have to trek to the east side the mar
vista studios the fly room the other
flyer there's a mistake linkedin back
home everything's okay yeah it's one
flying or driving me [ __ ] crazy
asleep I don't know why I like having
you know I get a connection to
housewives when I was a kid to staying
my grandmother always
house flies around at the farm so like
now there's house flies in miles i look
at them like pat my god we've got to
house legs like i don't know why but
like I [ __ ] dig it I'm gonna punch you
yeah i know i'm sorry why people like I
don't like it's so comfy thing for you
just like some weird thing about
football cuz my father would watch
that's when he would roll at cars and
foot box my father I was working on the
north uh oh [ __ ] so Top Gear's like a
huge thing it was a big thing that I've
emotional connection to cars cuz reminds
me the end football is listening to
football my father built you know built
our house and he was right the kitchens
and bathrooms is what he did um and he
put the radiant heat in our in our
basement so that's when the football so
I would lay on that we like lizards on
hot rod I am on the heat with the
football and that's that's the purple
season I get calmer doing football gets
all the way then yeah yeah that's not
easy to do I know but thats it thats you
can just you can tell Jets fans yeah and
I'm not even a football fear not easy
where did the jets play now I'm not
afraid I'm not a bad life with the
Giants they they're renting at
meadowlands now right yeah they're
metlife stadium is for me to met Lance
it used to be the metal answer now it's
called MetLife state okay so they're a
Giants tonight say they would finish the
play at Shea though they play a trail
that's why that's when I was a kid in
the second grade okay i did a report on
Joe Namath okay um and we know a to
chase stadium so I was like and then
they moved and then Shea Stadium was
always like it's French I remember going
to concerts at Giants Stadium well I
brendan byrne arena which is the street
from giant stadium in all the ranks did
he place with to Utley place for two
days yeah and all the all the jocks
would just [ __ ] throw rocks at us and
beer cans and wings [ __ ] with your
long hair oh she's great stead quiz yeah
I just beat the crap out of a son I
think this is less a man custo i'm
pretty sure that those guys still exist
yelling the same [ __ ] at picking other
kids are going to Mexico see ya re Adam
where can we find you besides top gear
at Adam Ferrara Twitter the facebook
awesome all the usual places come by say
hello tour schedules up there come and
see me excellent will will post the
the bit I was Professor Eddie free fell
I forgive me Eddie for forgetting and
we'll try to get any free felts names on
there and we'll put your link to your to
your site also uh first off Ian thanks
for sitting in the co-host seat thank
you I'll call you often and you often
see you so I appreciate it I love doing
it for a good friend attorney and Adam
we gotta get together have coffee since
your neighbor I'd like some time right
we got to get a whole let me see we got
Jake Johansson's right over there oh
yeah uh I did two drink minimum when
Jake had that show Wow to drink real I
remember that so man hoster yeah he
hosted it and I remember I did I did it
with Lewis Black okay cuz I remember me
me me me and me and Louie [ __ ] around
it in the green room yeah I always like
Jake i get it i did a she's [ __ ]
recon of him you chicken I did he it was
a true i was a guy who shot a trail to
sell him whose woods he would shoot the
trailer to sell the movie yeah and he
was in and I played some guy who lived
in a basement he was like the head I
remember I remember Jake was in I think
I hadley scenes with him but that's
hilarious yeah yeah there's a whole like
crew you know I apologize for saying
shitty movie I did a movie on a trail is
great Lisa [ __ ] I don't know that be who
else we got hey V in santa monica i see
hey V Bobby Collins right up here Bobby
better my own Bobby cow well what are
you cut your own hair what are you
pretty look Mary I'm gonna have to cover
up you know how we uh know how we I'm
from me you know how well the reason
what they used to kill me be like he'd
get the stand up on stage and his first
race be like Puerto Ricans what are you
doing huh are you guys doing just
serving were just think it was this
guide what's he doing it I thought I
work with I worked with Bobby in Vegas
last year and oh [ __ ] II everybody knows
Bobby Collins in Vegas like like dancers
you know work a Bobby are you in town
you're gonna come up after the show I
did a cruise ship me Bob I was a kid
with me Bobby I'm gonna say rondell
sheridan and Budd Friedman was one of
those improv cruiser bud like you Alex
let's go on a cruise I'll use the name
yeah so so we all did it I remember
Bobby did he bother just moved here or
something but he had a pool mm-hmm and
there was those giant ropes you know
giant ropes they used to tie the boats
up oh right right and he's like this
would look great by my pool Adam help me
get this in a bag I'm gonna be [ __ ]
from a point what's an eight-foot the
search money left by a [ __ ] row all
right great item thank you so much for
coming on tonight I will talk to you
soon man thanks a lot hey uh come see
both of these guys when they come to
your town they're very funny they
weren't listening us life on the road it
says taco dangling or strippers waving
guns and these flights canceled flights
running with the runs rooms like this
bounced checks great a bachelorette
pumps in the front making out for
yourself and the delights doing
Baltimore missing her turn try the
rental car has another megachurch drink
juice keys vagina Fister cell phone is
gone one big law and order
you